bientôt va disputer aujourd'hui aux
enfants pour cette seconde main sur
mortal kombat je vous ai promis que
j'allais m'entraîner c'est chose faite
c'est parti voici l'homme avec qui je
botte des culs au bâton voilà kong jean
et lui prend raiden ok on y va rater a
réussi réussi pardon réussi par donc
doublement ici hopla premiers coups de
bâton de la game c'est beau ça non non
non ça c'est moins beau ole ce cube ce
que j'avais prédit
ok c'est parti pour un petit combo des
familles on l'appelle le combo j'ai raté
il va toucher avec son sponsor qui fait
très très mal voilà il peut être la
colonne dans le ciel
on a rarement vu ça bon je laisse à
round avant ce qu'on est très gentil
dans le milieu vous avez bien voilà
c'est là que la vraie games va commencer
hockey aaa et là j'arrive là n'ont pu
perdre ce qui fait mal hop hop hop hop
hop hop hop hop hop hop
oh là là oh là là sous talent et non et
non et non un petit coup dans le tibia
ils sont faux en bas c'est la belle
attention c'est parti
ok on y va hop hop hop hop hop hop hop
s'il vous plaît ah non il me refais
étudiants ciel la journée main à un coup
de genou dans le dos y que je te casse
les vertèbres non mais ho et le trou de
la sécu après raiden qu'est ce que c'est
que ça allait voilà bientôt à bientôt à
les adversaires suivants 1
non tu prendras bateau fdp alors je te
me contre avec l air plutôt nul c'est
parti dix neuf victoires 45 défaites il
a refusé dans le mec était le mail 63
quand même hein c'est dire qu'elle fait
que de père depuis qu'il joue il fait
que de perdre tous les jours à les macs
soit guînes 64 ok ce parti a oui ok oui
hier en direct dans le peuple à moi les
gens comme ça je hockey et dès que tu te
remets bien aimé jetons chienne 1,1
attendu protégeant à léon ix
non voilà ah non elle a mis son
qui fait très beau poème 15 d'écho dans
la plus grande des violences ainsi que
la mâchoire tout le monde a un problème
non parce que j'ai cru que tu es en
train de te plains tu veux dire quelque
chose tu le dis a aucun souci mais tu
arrêtes un petit peu de nous faire chier
d'accord allait bientôt spectra le malin
c'est génial or je vais tomber contre un
mec à 100 victoires 0 défaite doit au
moins faire le malin tu veux choisir de
bons combattants
et ben adverse à suivre ça vous fera
rire à l'infini n'empêche c'est hyper
dur de se concentrer tout en parlant je
n'arrive pas à 72 victoires 27 défaites
parfait celle adversaire de taille qui
nous fallait et jouèrent maca il va nous
mettre une branlée
je pense qu'on va s'en souvenir
l'attention la concentration au voilà on
lui met un petit coup de bâton salle
stress un coup ça se voit ok on part sur
un combat parfait un combo on part sur
un petit combo il faut pas laisser j'ai
raté oh c'est beau on a gagné le premier
round bordel c'est incroyable ok on
recule à aucun rôle chacun sait la belle
aïe ça
tiens
on dira c'est tellement serré vgayet
avec le fameux petit coup du tibia on le
connaît bien
comment j'ai fait pour le bâti et est
tellement meilleur que moi ils me
servent hanche adversaires suivants on
connaît la fessée je suis le pire des
fdp 13-13 a il a pris le dessus
touati coup d'antibiotiques ont le tibia
voilà on les fait tomber les gens
ensuite il rate un petit peu leur leur
sort spécial donc ça fait plutôt plaisir
merde aux jolies c'était bon mais ça a
raté sa tâche et aplatit allez à bientôt
houle touché au monde va nous défoncer
on va le tenter en allant à perte parce
que la normalité c'est qui nous expose
d'ailleurs [ __ ] c'est parti je fais
chauffer le bâton 1up là il n'a rien vu
venir
il n'y a pas un combat qui fait plutôt
i'm à gaza la mâchoire dans la foulée ah
oui effectivement
effectivement il sait jouer au oui
est-ce que ça maintenant ça va lui
retirer ses devis attendez vous à voir
non ça va falloir tenir assez dit ça va
être tellement serré je prie je prie
je peux jouer est-ce que je peux jouer
juste n'ont pas l'eau bouillante dans
les yeux tapis que voilà gagné deuxième
round
ah non je croise une ouverture en
sautant a du coup il fait son combat
aussi non maman je le déteste le déteste
allez vas-y gagnent galles je te laisse
de la chaumière jeunesse la manette est
franchement s'est bien défendu pour un
mec aussi ce qu'il est que lui a versé
suivant tu es trop dessus pour nous car
une victoire 33 défaites level 61 allez
on y va
c'est parti oh mon dieu ma fonction je
suis trompé touche play a par avance aux
a été très favorable
ok on va le défoncer non j'ai raté non
c'est vous a coûté brunt mon dieu oh mon
dieu il a fabriqué les masses populaires
j'écoute le temps s'est arrêté à eux au
ok on va l'arrêter là c'est fini
oh oui haroun pour nous au [ __ ] c'est
tellement serré
j'ai tellement mal à parler je suis
tellement concentré et j'aimerais
tellement faire honneur là on gagne
contre ceux de sydney face ip regarde ce
qui peut lancer le truc qui ont eu toute
la vie quelqu'un là n'ont hélas raté
d'ânesse moi je ne demande pas mal de
gorge s'est desserré j'avais tous autant
suppression 54 victoires 2 sans défaite
tout ratio est plutôt négatif on va
tenter je déteste le froid je déteste la
glace
ah ok combo ah non pas tout de suite
ok c'est bon c'est maintenant ou jamais
ah oui on a gagné au pied cette fois
c'est promis je vais parler tout au long
du rhône
parce qu'à un moment ça suffit les
bêtises allez on y va elle est bien
faite à glissade fita glissade j'attends
je tape tombe à ok je n'attendais pas
tellement cette fois c'est lui
il a eu un break heures tiens mon gars
tu laisses tu vis de ce que je t'ai mis
au revoir
cet homme joue iron black l'homme au
pistolet on s'en souvient ah oui j'aime
pas trop le sabre à moi je suis plutôt
bâton comme tu peux le remarquer alors
ce quoi faire c'est que j'ai fait une
roulade arrière et je m'étais ce qu'il
est d'accord ok très bien tu es bien les
petits coups comme ça ou pas c'est très
serré mais malheureusement pour toi je
vais bien nier flèche coups de pied non
non et de rooney ont gagné la voyant ma
droite il a ses trois bars qui fait qui
peut lancer une attaque qui retire 36% à
billets des choses comme ça et qui vient
de la rater attention mesdames et
messieurs ça va commencer et j'ai raté
le dernier bouquet on l'a tué la tête
sur trois flèches que tu veux tarbes
auch
ok il fallut et foncé j'ai peur maman
méthode douce mais c'est incroyable
[ __ ] lui en plus ils le jouent à
distance avec ses tirs et où flash flash
non
je déteste ça mais pourquoi quelle île
il a gagné et on lui a retiré plus la
moitié de sa vie quand même pas lui
laisser le temps en fait voilà merci
pour tout fait pas de la serre suivant
je mets en revanche au collage tôt vers
tout de suite 35 % de chances de gagner
j'accepte ou à moisson n'a que 35 % de
chance mon gars
j'ai en tête non attention c'est la
suite les enfants c'est la suite je
déteste ce personnage
et ben non j'me chie dessus au 1 route
bardot raté raté ces satanés mec c'est
juste faire des statuts de l'asf [ __ ]
[ __ ] oui or comme c'est bon à a fois
je m'enflamme à oui oh oui oh oui oh oui
oh oui oh oui oh oui
non pas parce que tu es beau tu jamais
autant aimé voir une tête s'arracher et
atterrir sur trois flèches haut comme ça
aussi c'est glauque bordel tu veux
choisir un nouveau combattant retour au
menu principal on sait déjà que deux
vidéos sur mortal kombat vous avions
sans dépôt comme les sorties que la
première fois j'espère que ça vous a plu
et si vous avez aimé mes progrès
n'hésitez pas aimé la vidéo fut
progresse l'inami n'hésitez pas à me
dire si vous voulez une troisième vidéo
sur ce jeu avec un autre personnage que
j'essaierai de masterisé un portez vous
bien sûr tout le monde en piste